hang on to your ones because Harry
Potter is back well sort of our favorite
boy wizard isn't gracing the big screen
again
but his Wizarding World has expanded
shedding some light on one of the series
previously little-known characters Newt
Scamander fantastic beasts and where to
find them introduces a fuller version of
the guy previously best known in the
Potter universe for writing a Wizarding
textbook and while the new series
starter introduces a distinct time
setting characters and even vocabulary
elements there were some subtle nods to
the Harry Potter faith or you might have
missed and of course does not forget the
magic words spoilers ahead making a name
but biggest tie in-between Scamander and
the Potter universe while apart from
being a wizard of course is the fact
that he once wrote the book on Maggie so
ology that would later be taught at
Hogwarts fantastic beast takes place
long before New Sun ecology would become
a part of Hogwarts curriculum so it was
something of a nod to the pot around
that newts new girl tina gives us
manuscript a name we all know the tiny
giant suitcase the fact that newts
suitcase had a limitless interior size
was certainly a callback to things we'd
seen in the Harry Potter series before
consider how massive the Weasleys
Quidditch World Cup 10 was on the inside
the visual element of the atashi being
opened by prying claws to seem to like a
distinct winter sassy the monster book
of monsters that tormented Harry in
Prisoner of Azkaban
hufflepuff pride even though he's no
longer in good standing within the halls
of Hogwarts Newt Scamander
obviously doesn't hold anything against
his old house as evidenced by the
Hufflepuff colored scarf tucked away in
his briefcase the best Wizarding school
in the world Digital gorge hogwash it's
a good thing he's not bitter towards his
old institution because we know his
future grandson Rolf is due to marry
Hogwarts resident weirdo Luna Lovegood
down the line Quidditch quit
Quidditch was a beloved aspect of the
Wizarding World throughout the Harry
Potter series and new to makes a small
reference to the sport when he's asked
whether he's a seeker his response he's
more of a chaser really that of course
as a reference to his choice of field
position but perhaps if he had spent
more time seeking the Golden Snitch it
would have better prepared him for the
beat's grappling duties in this
installment Merlin's beard even though
American muggles are called no Maja's
and there's plenty of other new
terminology to take in during fantastic
beasts there's one turn of phrase as a
direct quote of a line from the Harry
Potter films Merlin's beard where have
you heard that before
[Music]
there are also some familiar spells and
Wizarding entryways and this floating
Apple that eats itself in front of the
boys as director winter Potter as they
come behold the NIF Fleur the nefler
might be new to the big screen with
fantastic beasts but the adorable mould
of Porcupine mix creature has long
existed in the written realm of magic
although the fantastic beasts never made
the cinematic cut for Goblet of Fire he
gets more than adequate screen time in
fantastic beasts there are other
creatures who'd be mentioned before but
only made their screen debut in
fantastic beasts including the size
shifting Arkham II and the disappearing
dummy guys but the NIF lair is a real
adorable hero of this movie
Dumbledore before we didn't get to see
our favorite headmaster in fantastic
peace but he did get a major mention
that proves he's alive and well as his
movie and faults thrown out of Hogwarts
for endangering
human life that was matched with a beast
he had one of your teachers argued
strongly against your expulsion now what
makes Albus Dumbledore so fun of you we
can probably expect to actually see him
show up in the next installment of this
series because there's another important
character coming into play as well they
will have a lot to do with Gellert
Grindelwald 2.0 Polyjuice potion
impersonations ran rampant throughout
the Harry Potter series - perhaps the
big twist in fantastic beasts that is
that Gellert Grindelwald had disguised
himself as Percival graves throughout
most of the events of the movie
shouldn't have been a surprise but the
reintroduction of Grindelwald does set
the stage for some interesting character
history to come especially when it comes
to Professor Dumbledore in the final
Harry Potter movies we learn that the
pair once worked together to recover the
Deathly Hallows in hopes of making the
world a better place
but their friendship soured after
Grindelwald began dabbling in the dark
arts their daughter come will be one for
the ages the strange family history the
Lestrange family became a major part of
the mayhem that arose at lord
voldemort's end but fantastic beasts
proves there was more to their backstory
than we might have guessed before
Bellatrix and Narcissa carried their
family into the dark lords corner there
was Lisa liitle estranged doesn't get
much discussion in the first fantastic
beast movie but we do find out she was a
former friends flash flame of newts who
apparently betrayed him count on her to
come back and have some part in Gellert
Grindelwald attempt to establish a new
world order for sure the Deathly Hallows
if there's one thing that could not be
hidden during fantastic beasts it's the
symbolism of the Deathly Hallows in the
movie Grindelwald posing as graves gives
our new pal credence a deathly hallows
necklace much like the ones we've seen
before in the Harry Potter movies this
is also a clear reminder that the
Deathly Hallows are going to be a big
part of the battle to come I want to be
lizard thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your love to
you